5回に分けて ありのままの自分という
テーマでお話ししたいです
大体わからないんですね
ありのままの自分というのは何なのかと
まあ一応言葉としてはね
ありのままの自分でいたいとかね
まあみんな言ったりはしますけど
それは何なのかと わからないで
ありのままのいられるわけでもないし
だからまあ そういうポイント
ありのままの自分って何なのかっていうところを
理解するために  5つに分けて話していきます
大体はテーマダブったりする可能性あります
なかなか 5つに分けられるぐらいのものでもないので
本当は今日のテーマで全部終わるはずぐらいなんですけど
まだですか まあ一応言っているところはほとんどスクリーンに映しますから
ただ 私の発音が理解できない場合はスクリーンで読んでも構いません
読んだ方がよろしいと思います
で また日本語の間違いとかいっぱいありますから
まあ自分がWord打ったものですので
その都度は直します 一応あの
それで あの 5つの共通テーマがありのまま自分を発見することで
今日の題は意外と気づかない自分の本音ということで
それで副題は皆さんも何回も読まれるようになったと思いますけど
人は世間体と建前で生きるということなんです
あまり仏教で考えるテーマではないんですけどね
私もこの本音と建前という言葉っていうのは
日本に来て初めて聞いたんであって
あまり英語にしたっても
そんなに使っている言葉ではありません
でまあ単語とか言語学的にはコンノテーション
ディノテーションとかいろいろ言葉ありますけど
それはすごい論理的なことで
あまり精神的な本音 建前とかね
ないんですよ 仏教は だから仏教でもそんなに扱っているテーマではないんです
それでも仏教の目で見ればどうなるのかと
じゃあ一応見てみましょう
えっと まずこの二重構造二重人格構成
だから本音と建前で言えば二重人格構成でしょ
で それが一般的なんです
あの あまり悪い意味で取る必要はないんです
人間といえば本音と建前という二重構成でできているんです
だから まあ悪い言葉で言えば二重人格なんです
多重人格というよりは二重人格で私たちは生きているんです
それではもう二重人格が悪いと思ったら
では一重の一重の人格はどうですかね
これが社会的な人生ではないんですよ
ただ思ったものはその通りに言うとかね
やりたいことはそのままやってしまうとか
例えば電車に乗って自分で座りたくなった人がずっと座って座ってるんですね
まあどきなさいと言ってドカンと座ったりするとね
そうすると正直でいいでしょ
はっきりしてるんだから
まあ一重だから人格は
でもその社会的じゃないでしょうに
そんなもので生きていられません
だからこの二重人格っていうのは
もう要は二重人格で言ったらなんか嫌な感じがするでしょ
だったら一重はどうでしょうかと
これはとんでもないことなんです
で 二重人格でなければ
文明人として生活できない
人間というのは文明作って
もう社会を作って生きているんだから
我々文明人として生きているでしょうに
ということは もう二重人格ということなんです
これもどうにもならないんです
文明人としては生きていられない
二重性は人によって まあそれはテーマはちょっと変わりますから
で それで一重 本音建前ない人と言えば
もうほとんどこのこの社会で生きていられない
もう社会に入れて困る人間なんです
それで人間というのは社会人であって
しっかり生きているということは
確実に本音と建前というものはあるということなんです
二重でできているんだということなんです
自分がいて 社会との関わりを持っている自分がいるんです
自分二人がいるんです
それでこの 他人との関係で
二重性は人によって違います
それ次に考えてみましょう
それで二重性っていうのは本音と建前なんですね
みんな同じじゃないんですよ
私の本音と他の人の本音が違う
そうすると 本音に本音に支えて現れる建前も変わっちゃうんですよ
困ったことに  それはすごい分かりやすい例で言えば分かります
例えば私 二人が人が二人がいる
そこで何か一個の品物がある
一人がそこが好きで好きでたまらない
もう一人がそれ嫌です
そこでこの持っている人とこの二人が喋ると態度が違うんですよ
欲しくてたまらない人は色んなことで褒め称たり
おだてたりして これ美味しいな
いいものだなとかね なんとかなんとか言うでしょうね
だからくれということなんで
それは言わないんです
それ言わないで ああ なんていいものかなとかね
そこで  それはあんまり好きじゃない
嫌いな人は別に話を逸らしたり
別なことを言ったりする
だから そのその本音によって建前が変わっていくんです
例えばその 3番目の人とはコミュニケーションを取りたい
で いない品物はあまり好きじゃない人はあなたこれ電車で持ってきたんですかね
さぞ重かったでしょうねとかね
どうです この頃もう仕事でうまくいってるんでしょうかとか
そういう風に建前喋ったりして
これ欲しくてたまらん人はあの品物を褒めたり
おだてたり 別なコミュニケーションを取ったりする
そういうことで理解してほしいのは
一人一人の本音が違うし
それなりに建前も違うということなんです
だからこれがトラブっちゃうんですよ
だから我々は他人とこの本音で繋げて繋げなくちゃいけないんだからトラブっちゃうんです
そこで今の例であの品物を持ってる人が
これは決して人に触らせても欲しくないぐらいすごく執着を持ってるとどうなるんですかね
この 1番目のとこれ好きで好きでいろいろ
もうくれっていうこと言えないんだから
なんかいろんなこと言ってるんでしょうね
ああ ありがたいな これ重いでしょうねとか何とか言って
で 相手の方が触るなよという態度取っちゃうでしょう
そうするとそちらにぶつかったりするんですよ
こちらが触るところはこれ持っていきたいのに
向こうは触らせてもくれないと
そちらへの対立が生まれるんです
そこでもう一人の方が別にそれに興味ないでしょ
だからどうですか もう今仕事でもうまくいってるんでしょうかとかね
子供たち元気？とか何とか言っちゃうと
その人とうまくはめるでしょうに
これ触ろうともしないし
そこでこの品物を持ってる人が
あ この人がすごく相性が良くていい人間やと
この人はすごくいやらしい人間だとすぐ決めつけたりする
だからそうやってコミュニケーションの世界でこのトラブルが起きたり
混乱したりする だから
これにはもう一般的な何か対処法はあるかというと
これがもうなかなか大変ですよ
なぜならば この本音そのもの
人によって違うでしょうし
だから 誰が誰と付き合うとどうすればいいかということは
そのケースバイケースで言わなくちゃいけない
こんなのは言えたものじゃないんです
1億人の人に 1億人 1億種類の方法を言わなくちゃいけないんだから
だからもう大変なことなんです
だからそこまでは理解していただければ
この問題が起こるんだと
本音と建前のことで だったら本音で言えばね
これ私にくれと そしたら向こうはえ？あげませんよと
触るも触ることも嫌ですよと
それで相手もケチと言って
それで終わっちゃうんですよ
あんたケチですかと 向こうはケチで悪かったと言えば
それで話は別になんのことなく
互いに仲良く終了しますよ
でも そういうわけにはいかないんですよ
それからこの本音の特色があります
あの  できるだけ早く話を終わりたいと思っています
で それでいろいろ質問やらね
アイデアやら交換したいものがあれば
まあ本音は置いておいて
建前ででもぶつかってみるもありがたいんじゃないかなと
で 意外とこの本音建前っていうのは日本語ですよ
こんなに明確な用語があるのは
なんとか形で他の国々の言葉でも言えないわけないんだけど
で なかなか私の頭に思い浮かばないんですよ
他の言語で何言うかなということは
だからこれ明らかに日本語なんですね
日本語の言葉なんです
なのに意外と本音っていうのは分かってないというかね
言葉あるっていうことははっきりわかってるっていうことですけどね
ですから 私は大きなお世話かもしれませんだけど
本音に特色というものを説明したいと思います
で 他人に決して見せないもの
本音っていうのは当たり前
他人に見せない 他人に見せるんだったら本音じゃないでしょうし
だからそこをみんなはっきり理解していないんですよ
本音だったら もういくらなんでも他人に言ったり見せたりするものじゃないんです
なのにすぐすぐ言っちゃうでしょ
これ大変なことになりますよ
だからそれは本音のことをわかってない
まあまあいいんじゃないかということで
ちょっと言ってみたところで
もう大変なトラブルが起きたりしますよ
離婚までなっちゃうんですよ
あなたと一緒にもうもう私は 30年も一緒にいたのに
もう嫌だ もうやめるぞとか
そういうことになる時もありますよ
だから結局は本音っていうのは他人に言わないっていうのは原則ですよ
そういうふうに稀なケース以外は良いものだと思わない
大体本音っていうのは
誰もこれすごく美しくて良くて立派なものやと思ってないんです
本音で言えばもう臭いということになってるんです
それも一つの特色なんですね
稀なケースと書いたのは
これほとんど病気ですよ
自分の本音はすごく立派でできていると
自分ができた人間だと本気で思っちゃうと
まあ病院に行った方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
だから稀なケースと書いたんです
で 本音は善だと思われる場合も
必ずその通りだと言えない
一般的には本音っていうのはまあ臭いということに決まってますけど
時々 いえ 私はそれなりに正直に生きてるんだと
自分で自分の本音は正直で勤勉で怠けないで責任果たしてしっかり生きてる人やと思ってる場合ありますよ
でも必ずしもそうっていうことはないんです
本人がそう言っても だから本音で思っても事実は違う
それも気をつけた方がいいんです
時々いますでしょ 皆様の社会でも自分の人格をすごく自慢げに後輩に喋ったり
押し付けたりする人々が
私はね もう一日も若い頃
一日に一時間半も寝ていないんだぞとか
毎日本は十冊読みましたよとかね
今あなた方は何ない何なのかと
怠けてばっかし遊びばっかしとかね
そういう場合はやっぱり自分がすごい勤勉で本気で頑張ったというふうに思ってますけど
もう事実はそうじゃない場合もほとんどほとんどです
だからそう気にする必要はないんですよ
人がそうやって本音自慢しても
隠すものになっているので
本人も子供頃から本音をわからなくなる
これはどういう意味でしょうかね
一応本音っていうのは隠すもの
それで皆様は子供育てたでしょ
小さい時から子供はどういうふうに育ったんですか？全部本音隠せということを教えたんです
これがみっともないとかね
カッコ悪いとかね 人の前でそんなこと言うなよとかね
あのおじいさんにちゃんと挨拶しなさいとかね
子供は嫌やと言うんだけど
それ子供の本音なんですけど
そんなこと言ったらあかんよ
ちゃんと挨拶しなさいとかね
そうやってもう一歳二歳の時からもう子供に本音を隠せということを教えているんです
そこが幼稚園でも教えて
小学生でも学校でも教えて
中学校でも教えて もうやがて大学までも同じことを教えているんです
だからもう考えてください
二歳の時隠しておいたものがわかるわけないでしょうに
例えば幼稚園で一緒に遊んだ友達の名前を言ってくださいったら覚えてないでしょう
私はまるっきり覚えてないんで
幼稚園に行ったことはないんですけど
まあ中学生 小学生も全然名前覚えてないんです
だから小さい時からも隠しなさいと言ってるんだから
もう隠しちゃったんです
それが何やと今更はわからないんです
自分の本音は  [紙の音]そういう
そういうことで それで本音の特色終わり
それが本音の特色 わからない
隠すもの そこで隠すものではなくて
自分の本音ぐらいはすごい綺麗や立派だと思ったっても
あまり相手にしない方がいいという
で それから次に行きます
いじめられた本音 かわいそうに我々本音をいじめているんです
これをちょっと説明しましたけど
子供から子供頃から受けるしつけ
教育とは いかに上手に建前を演じるかです
私たちの教育っていうのはそんなもんですよ
いかにいわゆる社会人になることでしょ
だから本音が建前のやり方なんです
人がいて 社会との関わりは本音で建前で関わっているでしょうし
学校に行ったら社会人になる教育を受けるでしょうに
だから明らかにそれは上手に建前を演じる
演じるんです これが建前を演じるで本音っていうのはかわいそうですよ
全く違うものを演じているんだから
悔しくてたまらんですよ
例えば皆様の会社で自分が一生懸命 2 3
ヶ月間も苦労して何か研究して何か品物を開発したら
それは課長か部長かがそうもう社長にそれは見せて
自分が褒めてもらったりして
それで自分だけボーナスも得たりすると悔しくないんですかね
で これ何か要するに自分をただ昇格も降格させたりしちゃうと
これは腹が立つでしょうに
だからそういうことを我々自分にやっているんでしょう
だから建前を見事に演じるということはならんのです
それで演じれば演じるほど
本音がえらくいじめられて
大変苦しい 苦しんでいることになるんです
それから正直に建前を受け止められる子もいるが
それはできなくて困る子もいる
そういうことで このいいことを
いいものを演じられる子っていうのは個人という意味で書いたんです
全部書ける場所がないので
そちらは 日本語って何でも省略するんだから
でもそんな省略では困りますけど
まあ一応子と書いたのは個人ということで
で この上手に演技が 演技上手な個人もいますよ
でもそれほど上手でない大根役者もいます
社会では そこで上手に本音を演じられない人っていうのは
かなり社会で社会人として苦しいんです
それからこのよくみんな謳っている言葉がありますね
ストレスという言葉が
そこで何かストレスというのは
これは悪いという意味ではなくて
ストレスたまっても何か威張ってます
自分がすごく忙しい 忙しくて仕事をいっぱいやったりして
まあという感じなんですけど
でも本人は体も精神もやられていることも確かでしょうし
それでこのよく言うのは
どんな人間にもストレスがあるんだよと
ストレスがない生き方はできないんだと
人間であるならばストレスがあるんだと
あれどういうことかと
ストレスというのは 仕事をする時
社会といろんな関わりを持って
いろんなことをやっていると起こるものでしょうに
それでやっぱり建前と本音の問題なんです
仕事をしたり 社会で社会人として活動したりするということは
建前の舞台 劇場ですね
で それと本音 この舞台の裏にいる
何でしたっけ そういう裏で仕事をする人
本音には大変 かみ合わない
もうついていけない時もあります
例えば舞台で考えると
舞台の裏で照明やら舞台の色々変わることやら
背景変わることやら ものすごいたくさん仕事あるんですよ
もし舞台の場面があまりにも激しく変わると
裏で仕事をする人々にもどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
機械なんか動かせなくなっちゃうんです
例えば照明入れ替えたりしたっても
ある時間感覚が必要ですよ
パチパチと光変わっちゃうと
もうお客さんにはもう何も見えなくなっちゃって
もう頭がもうおかしくなっちゃうし
だからすごい光出したところで
次に暗い場面だったら
すごい光はゆっくり下がって暗くしなくちゃいけない
いきなり暗くしちゃうと
もうみんな停電やと勘違いするんですよ
だから もし舞台で場面があまりに激しく動くと
舞台裏で仕事をする人々にはもう手に負えない状態になるんです
ストレスっていうのはそんなもんなんですよ
我々は建物であれもやってこれもやっても
いろんなことをやっていると
本音はなかなかもうついていけなくなっちゃうんです
調子聞かなくなっちゃう
それでもうそこでストレス溜まったりする
だからこの本音と現状の対立ですね
ストレスというのは まあそういうことで
そういう風に我々は本音をいじめているんです
いじめは良くないんですよ
これは本当に良くないことなんです
では 本音いじめないと正直でしょうね
正直な人間って何なのかと考えてみましょうか
まだありますか？もうちょっといじめられると吸い込まれます
それで一般的には本音またいじめられますね
わがまま 本音だけで生きてる人にと本音あまりにももろに出しちゃうと
我々はわがままなやつやと侮辱するんですよ
何が侮辱されてます？自分の本音が侮辱されてるんです
次に この抑圧すること
壊すこと 良いことだと思っている
みんなそう思ってますよ
本音なんかはやっぱり抑圧した方が
抑えた方がいい そんなのはもう良くない
悪い 壊した方がいい と思っちゃうと本音が怯えるんじゃないんです
俺を殺そうとしてるんでしょうかと
なんだこの人 私を殺す意図てるんではないかと本音が怯えるんですよ
だからそういうことを常に我々やってますよ
怒ってはあかんとかね
あの人を憎しんではあかんとか
なんで私は他人を憎しむんでしょうかとか
いろんなことで 結局は自分の本音を脅しているんです
脅かさせてるんです 大変なことなんです
それには本音の実態は知らないのに
何を抑圧すれば良いのでしょうか？それは私の疑問なんです
本音を制御するべき 抑圧するべき
なくすべきということ
口先では言うんだけど
本音って何？わかってないでしょうに
だから何を抑圧するんですかね
そこら辺で我々はちょっと疑問になるんです
人は正直に生きたいが
それは決してできない
これが本音ですよ これが一つの本音なんです
人っていうのは正直に生きたいんですよ
しかし 決してできない
正直に生きること はい
これで録音いきます それから正直っていうのは何なのかと
正直な人間 それは世間で言う正直なんですね
この世間で正直な人間というのは
まあ本音をモロに見せる人
もう誰かが本音をモロに見せちゃうと
我々はお世辞的に正直だと言うんです
あれお世辞 お世辞ですけどね
時々あまり悪くない本音出しちゃうと
正直な人だと言うんです
悪い本音出しちゃうと
あまりもう気分が良くないんですけどね
一応正直っていうのは
まあどうしたことない
モロに見せるんですよ
本音を それで一般的に馬鹿
無知だと言われる人 当たり前ですよ
正直な人は馬鹿だと平気で言ってるでしょうに
だから本音っていうのは隠すべきものですよ
隠せないんですね あの子供
ちっちゃな子供たちの
あれ 何か 何か鬼ごっこやってるでしょ
もう隠してる 隠れてるつもりなのに
足があっちこっち見えるんですね
カーテンの裏に隠れて
もう足がもう見事に見えてるんです
まあそんな感じで子供はそういうことをやったってもね
まあ可愛いんですけど
でも大人がそういう感じで言っちゃうと
あまり可愛くないんですね
だから一般的に正直な人っていうのは
社会では正直にバカという人なんです
無知ということなんですよ
それで正直な人には社会性はないんです
ありますかね 社会性という言葉は正しいかどうかは分かりませんだけど
いわゆる社会できちんと適応して
社会人としては生きていられないんですよ
正直な人には だってバカですからね
まあしょうがないんです
そこでもっとすごい正直だったら
もうあらゆる精神病になっていることなんです
あまりにも正直だったら
結構病気ということなんです
対人恐怖症 強迫観念等々いろいろあります
これは正直な人の問題なんです
これはちょっとあまり心理学的なこと説明したくないんですけど
例えば正直に自分がすごい可愛いと思っちゃう
大体若者にあるんですね
いつもこの精神病気を起こすのは
まあ十六から二十歳までですね
日本では まあ子供は成長早いんだから
まあ一応中学生の時でも引き起こしたりはする
小学生までは本当に可愛くて元気で
もう全く何もないんですよ
みんなもう同じ可愛い元気
勉強むちゃくちゃやる
これが中学校に上がって二
三年くらい経つと もうちらちらと見えてくるんです
で 高校生になってくるとかなり厳しいんですね
それで爆発するということになるんです
いろんな精神病気が だから
これどういうことかというと
この まあこの まあはっきりは母親のせいなんですよ
母親っていうのはこのもうやることはないんだから
もうもう自分のために子供を育てるんですよ
だからいいお母さんだと
もうかっこつけるために
もう何から何までやってあげたりして
子供にこの人生の教育をさせないんです
料理させない 洗濯させない
掃除させない 旦那よりもすごく丁寧に食卓に食事を用意して
それから食べてから もうちゃんと自分で片付けて
そういうふうなことで
このものすごく激しく子供をいじめるんです
心を壊すんです で 子供はなんだかんだで奴隷みたいにやってくれるんだから
まあ結構母親を可愛がっているんです
それで母がすっごく騙されるんです
うちの子ってなんて可愛いんですかと
なんていい子ですかと
これえらい勘違いで 十八くらいになってくると全部変わっちゃうんです
それで子供は何でもやってくれるものだと勘違いしている
自分がものすごい可愛いと勘違いしている
しかし 学校に行ったら自分だけじゃない
またいっぱいいるんですよ
学校で今日はクラスに座ってみれば
みんなブスやと言うんです
あの子はブスやと平気で同じ年同士だから言うんです
これ我慢できないんですよ
家に行ったら世界一美人で可愛いなのに
なんで学校の仲間たちは自分のことをブスやと言うんでしょうかと
これ耐えられないんですよ
だから人を育ててないんです
母親が これでもう頭が爆発しちゃうんですよ
対人恐怖症やらもう社会に映え入らなくなったりとかね
ああ 怖い怖いとか言ったりとか
土曜もそういうちょっとしたケースが現れましたけどね
あまり言えないんですから
私 本当のことは で あれは怖い
これが怖いとかね それで怖いって言ったって
学校に行きなさいと何とか言っちゃうと
あんた何言ってるんでしょう
これで母親に当たったりするんですよ
本人の苦しみなんか分かってないんで
本当に苦しんでますよ
だから学校に行きなさいよと
会社に行きなさいと言っちゃうとも
言ってはいけないんですよ
本人にとってはもう鬼ですよ
学校やら会社やらもうものすごい凶暴な獣をあっちこっちもう住んでいる
もううろうろしているすごい巨大な森なんです
それに行け行けと母親言うと
母親って本当に親切な人かという疑問はさらに子供が思っちゃうんです
だからそれでトラブルが起きたりするんです
だからこの正直の問題
それなんですよ だから正直っていうのはちょっとおかしい言葉なんですけど
子供は正直に自分が可愛いと思ったことのせいなんです
だから逆に小さい時から
うちの母はもうバカもいいところやと平気で母をバカにしたり
からかったりする子供は全然社会的な問題を起こさないんですよ
面白いことに バカではうちの母ちゃんだと平気で言う子は
本当はお母さんのこと好きなんですよ
心配もしているんです
でも 母の奴隷にはならないんです
母の奴隷になるんじゃなくて
私が母を守ってあげるぞという態度を取ってるんです
人をバカにしちゃうとかなりやられるということは子供は知ってるんだから
まあだったらお母さん馬鹿にしてやると
お母さんからはもう攻撃来ないんだから
ということで まあちょっと遊んでるだけのこと
だからそういう態度を取る子っていうのは
あまり精神的な問題を起こしません
しかし いい子を演じる人っていうのは
まあ気をつけた方がいいんです
で それであの 正直 社会に出会ってみると
自分が今まで思っていた本音とぶつかっちゃうんです
可愛いと思っていたのに
もう実際は可愛くないと
自分が痩せてると思ってたのに
実際は痩せてないと そういう比較するんだから
これでやられて病気になります
そこで人っていうのは本当に正直であれば極端な精神患者なんです
いるでしょう もう平気で人を殺したりとか
平気で まあ何て言いますか
レイプしたりとか それで
あの あれ 何て言いますか
この いる あっちこっち家に火をつけたりするケースあるでしょ
放火魔とか ああいう人って正直ですよ
本当に正直なんです 思ったことをやるんだから
それで極端な犯罪者も正直なんです
あの この いきなり もういきなりではなくて
あっちこっち人を殺す殺す
10人とか 20人とか
時々現れますね このイギリスでも何回も現れましたよ
リッパーという特別な英語の単語までありますから
で 一番最初に記録されているリッパーっていうのは医者なんですよ
すごい社会的な立場がある立派な医者で
で 病院も治療しながら
午後ちょっと外に出て誰か殺してくるんです
何のことなく で また誰か殺してくるんです
そういう分も もう十何人も殺しちゃったりして
この最近出たケースは
またお城みたいに家に住んでる人で
これも 20人  30人ぐらいの子供たちを
女の子 女の子たちを殺してる
殺して自分の家で 家の中で
庭で埋めておく 本音がすごく正直で
何か考え方があって それで殺していくんです
それで最近逮捕している医者は
あの どこへ行っても患者さんに見るに家に呼ぶでしょ
呼んだら あの 薬を注射してもう安楽させてくれるんです
60歳 55歳  60歳で行っちゃうと
どうですか？お腹が痛い
胸も痛いんです はい わかりましたと
何のことなく いろいろ私
薬の名前わかりませんだけど
あの こういう心臓をね
止まったりする薬あるみたいんです
で それを取って注射して帰る
もう 100単義で殺してるんです
正直ですよ で 彼の考え方
おそらく別にそんな病気になってね
腎臓が悪いでしょうし
もうどんどん悪くなるでしょうし
若返るわけでもないでしょうし
まあ死んだ方がいいんじゃないか
この人 私 パッって感じで注射を打っても
だから正直っていうのはそういうことで
極端な犯罪者っていうことになるんです
それで これは掃除理論です
で 皆様驚くか気が立ってるか私はわかりませんだけど
誰でも私は正直だと言ったら
なんか褒め 自分で自画自賛したつもりでしょ
でも結局は本当は言わない方が
私はそんな正直なものじゃないと言った方がいいかもしれません
もうわかりますかね 世界使ってる言葉と中身っていうのはなんかすごく隔たりがあるんですよ
本当に文字通りで 正直って何なのかというと
もう血も涙もないとんでもない犯罪者なんですよ
全然正直でない人っていうのは結構安心して付き合えるんです
でも我々は違う考え方
言葉で違う 建前で違う言葉を言うんです
じゃあ次のスライドに進んでみましょう
しかし 世間は正直な人を褒め称える
あの極悪の犯罪者を世界は褒め称えているんです
正直っていうのはあんなもんだなのに
こんなもんですね 正直な人はかなり褒め称えたりする
まあそこはまあ結論で
まあ結論になりませんね
なんか対立論みたいな
なんて言ったらいいかわかりませんですけど
一応新たに考えてください
正直っていう概念は まあブッダの話だから
この なんか軽く聞こえるんですけど
これはすごく難しい心理学なんです
お釈迦様の話っていうのは
だから私はもうできるだけわかりやすく軽くして
軽くして喋るんであって
レベルダウンしてはないんです
これ言ってる人の一つの言葉にいつでも裏があるんです
かなり情報も入ってはいるんです
ですから 本音と建前って何なのかとかね
では正直って何なのか
本音建前ダメ 邪魔 邪魔だったら悪いだったら
では正直できてればいいんではないかというと
正直っていうのはあんなもんなんです
本音建前いいやと言ったっても結構苦労する
だったら俺は本音建前なくない
正直に生きてみるぞと言っちゃうと
もう精神的にもうイカれたということになる
どうすればいいか そこで世間はその上
正直なものを褒め称えたりする
バカやと言いながら褒め称えるんです
では次に考えますよ だったら正直な人間って何なのかと
正直でない人間 これの反対の言葉を知らなかったんですから
正直でない人間とか言ったんですけど
何て言いますか 正直でない
不正直とか 狡猾  まあ正直でない人というと
世間 世間はズルいと言うんです
平気でずる賢い 我がなくなってますけど
まあずる賢い かなり侮辱されてますね
正直でない場合は詐欺師やとかね
偽善者とか信頼できないものだとか
裏切り者とか 結構やられますよ
正直でないならば 要注意人物ととかなどのレッテルが貼られる
だからみんな正直というふうに言い張ってます
本当は正直じゃないんですよ
一人も 正直だったらもうとっくに刑務所にいるんだから
誰も犯罪を起こさないでいるんだから
正直じゃない 一人も 正直でないのに
みんな俺は正直だよと平気で言ったりするんです
なぜかというと 世間がそうやって嫌なレッテルを貼るんです
だから私たちは本当に困るんですよ
正直だったら犯罪を起こして刑務所に行くでしょうに
私たちは犯罪は起こしたくないでしょうに
法律守って普通に生きていきたいでしょ
だから法律犯罪を起こしたことはない
だから平和でいるということは
一人も正直者はいません
しかし それ私は正直でないと言っちゃうと
こんなレッテルを貼ってくれるんだから
自分が正直だと嘘を言うことになっているんです
はい それで正直でない人っていうのはもうちょっと違う特色もあります
一応前言ったのは単なるレッテルばっかりですけど
本音が見え隠れしていて
正直でないということは
もうなんか本音見えたりする
見え隠れたりする  そう
他人におそかれ早かれバレる
自分の本音は 目的に達する方法が世間から見ると乱暴なやり方です
世渡りが上手ではない
内向き そちらポイント 1つありますが
もう一度ちょっと考え直しましょう
本人が見え隠れしていて
例えば訪問販売に来て
品物を売ったりすると
余計に品物を褒めるでしょ
これがもうあればもうこれは決まり
これは決定版だなんだとか言ったりするでしょうね
大体あれがもう本当のことじゃない
ただ売りたくて言ってるあの宣伝文句なんですね
時々あの まあ本人の口からバレちゃうんです
質問されたりすると まあそれはちょっとわからないんだとかね
このこのものを買えばこうこうなるんでしょうかと
これあ これはちょっとわからないとというと
あ この人は正直じゃないんだと
それは本当にバレちゃったんですよ
本音が 大体この人間の場合はね
本音がバレたりすると
私たちはすぐあの人は正直じゃないと平気で言う
逆なんですけど 本音がバレるということは正直なんですけど
弱くて下手くそで 例えば
あなたは本当にこの品物がいいんだから訪問販売しているんでしょうか？と聞いたら
え？そんなことはない
俺も何か仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
私は品物を売って金儲かれればそれで十分やと言っちゃうと
この人は正直じゃないと平気で言うんです
本人は本当に正直なことを言ってますけど
奥さんにこれが役に立とうが立たないが関係ないんだよと
買ってくれと だったらもうものすごい失礼な人ではないかとということになります
そこで他人におそかれ早かれバレるんですよ
本音が 例えば 5 年間もある人と付き合っていて
あなたしかこの世の中で私にもう誰もいないんだとかね
そうと付き合っていると
女の子ももうその気になっちゃって
この人は私に即婚やと
でもその人は二股かけている
もう一人女の人とはもう付き合っている
それで見事にお互いにバレないようにする
でも 5年経ったところでやっぱりバレちゃったと
そうするとあの女の子何言うんでしょうかね
裏切り者 騙しやがったと
私を だから正直な人にそういうレッテルを貼れるんですよ
だから正直でない人にというか
なんかわからない 私もわからなくなっちゃった
正直でないと我々言ってる人は
結局は本音がバレるんですよ
遅かれ早かれ だから我々は正直でないと言うんです
だから 5 年間付き合った女の子があの男は全く不誠実で
もう信頼できないと言うんです
それは本音バレたんだからでしょ
もし本音バレなかったら全然大好きだよと言うんです
そこでこの目的に達する方法が一応乱暴
その時の正直ではないと言うんです
例えばもうまあもう八百屋さんやっていて
もう店も早くもう終わりたいし
まあちょっとちょっと野菜が残っていて
それで奥さんが来て じゃあこちらであの 100グラムくださいと
はい わかりましたと  100グラム売ってもまだ 50グラムは残ってて
これは売れないんで  100グラム単位でしか
というと 奥さんどうですか
これ全部持っていったら
まあ一応まけてあげますから
100グラム 例えば 400円で言えば
600円でどうですかね
まけてあげます まけてないんですけど
また買うとやっぱり 800円もなるんだから
じゃあ 600円で じゃあもう持ってき持ってきって
もう奥さんだからもう本当にもう商売上がっちゃいます
なんとか言って売っちゃうんです
ほんなら家に帰ってみたら
あれ 騙されたではないかと
あの商人が乱暴でというふうにね
でも本人がかなり早く自分の目的に達する
だから世間で結構この成功している人々に対して
我々言うでしょ？すごい乱暴だと
あの最近逮捕されたあの金融関係の社長って何でしたっけ？竹藤のものすごい悪口あるでしょ
殴ったりまでするんだと
でもそれバレるまではかなり褒め称えていたんですけど
立派な人だと で 本人が随分早く自分の目的に達しちゃったんで
それから潰れたんですけど
だからこのちょっと乱暴だから
私たちは不誠実 不正直な人間だと
悪人だと 悪い人やとレッテル貼る
まあそんなもんですね
世渡りが上手でないと当たり前ですね
ただ 本人が世渡りが下手だけのことなんですけど
私たちは正直でない人間だと言うんです
世渡り上手っていうのは
もうおだてるべき人はちゃんとおだてて
もういろいろもうお辞儀するべきところにちゃんとお辞儀をしてとかね
そういう生き方ちゃんとするんですね
ちゃんとお中元を持っていって
そういういろいろやり方やる
それができない人に対しては
もう正直じゃないという風に言っちゃうんです
まあできないわけではなくて
何でもいいからもう中元持っていかなくちゃあかんかとか思ったりするかもしれません
うるさい めんどくさいと
そうすると正直にやらなかっただけかもしれません
でもそんなことうるさい
めんどくさいと言ったっても
世渡りということもありますから
やっぱりやった方が良かったんですけど
やらなかったんですね
それでまあ正直でない人になっちゃうんですね
それから内向き 自分の気持ちを考えるんですよ
やりたくないという自分の気持ち
それでもう正直でないということになっちゃうんです
例えば子供が学校に行きたくないという場合は
これは内向きで自分の気持ちなんです
それでみんな世界が何言ってるんでしょうかと
常識は学校に行くことではないかと我々は言う
言っても子供は聞かない
内向き 自分の気持ちに正直
その時は我々はもう言うことを聞かない人や
もうあれこれとかも言うんですよ
では 3番目のこれは普通の人なんです
それで正直な人の説明終わりましたし
正直でない人の説明終わりましたし
まあ普通の人って誰ですかと
まあどちらも良くないでしょ
正直で人も正直でない人も
普通な人っていうのは本音がバレない
本音がバレない 気づかさず世間を騙す
見事に相手を騙して自分の目的に達する
全然バレない それは普通の人なんです
自分は正直者だと自分に言い聞かす
自己 するんです 自己暗示して何でもやるんです
そこで社長があなたをクビにするぞと言うと
社長の前でも泣き崩れて
社長のためなら私はもう地獄でもどこでも行くんだぞとか
なんとか見事に演じたりして
それで首を繋げてもらったりとか
あるいはずっと社長の個人的な家にまでいて
家の掃除洗濯までして
奥さんの機嫌まで取って自分の首を繋げてもらう
そうすると あの人はなかなかやり手で
あの会社ではなかなかもうクビにならないんだと
そういう生き方してますよ
これ大会社とかみんなやってます
そんなの いろんなからくり
いろんな悪いこと いろんな談合やらいろんなことがあって
決してバレないようにすると
ものすごく認めるんです
だいたい普通の人間っていうのはそんなもんなんですよ
本音を認める場合でも
それ自体が理想的で素晴らしいものだと公言する
で  3番目に書いたのは
この普通の人間っていうのは
人にはあまり言わない
私は正直な立派な人間と言わないんだけど
私はまあまあ言うことはない
だらしないとかみんなに言うんです
本音 建前 言うんだけど
心の中では俺は完璧な人間だ
俺にはもう勝てる人間はいるわけじゃないんだと
ちゃんと金儲けてみせるのではないかと
俺には間違いはありませんと
不可能という単語は私にはないんだぞという生き方をしているんです
いわゆる自己暗示かけてるんです
他人には言えないんだけど
時々自己暗示かけることではなくて
バカがいるんで 私は本当に正直だという人もいますよ
自分の本音を認めようとするときも
自分がすごく理想的で完璧で正しい生き方をしているんだと世間に言うんです
それが普通な人間です
分析がこの初めてやったものだから
ちょっとわかりにくいところはあるかもしれませんけど
まあ正直な人間もろくなことはないという
普通の人間もろくなことはないということなんです
だから皆様が自分がどちらに入るかと
正直な人間に入るか 正直でない人間のカテゴリに入るか
普通の人間になりたくてどちらか決まったから決めたらどうでしょうかと
では そちらの結論は 結局は世間を見事に騙して成功を収める人は普通な人なのです
書いてあります 普通な人々
みんな普通な人々なんです
で 右側にいるこの女性のイラストでも
左側にあるみんな仲良くうまく付き合って生活していて
それで商談成立すると
それが普通の人生でしょ
だからバレないということなんです
あの写真の女の子の表情表情わかりますか？バレないと思いますよ
泣いてるか わかってるか
笑っているか 相手をバカにしているか
えーと では それがそれなりの結論です
とにかくろくなことない
えーと 正直だと言っても危なくてたまらない
正直でないと言ったっても
ろくなことではありません
では 私は普通やと言ったっても
こんなもんで 世間は見事に騙すということで
正直でないっていうのはすごく弱いんでバレるんですね
自分の本音が 本音がバレなきゃ普通の人間なんです
だから結局騙し合いなんです
結局は演じがどういう人かっていうことなんです
それと私は最初に言った言葉と組み合わせなくちゃいけない
そんな悪いんだったら
我々は建前なしに生きてられるかって
生きていられるわけないんですよ
建前取ってしまえば野蛮人だから
ブッダ人じゃないんです
だからもう結構はめられてますよ
逃げられないようにと
じゃあ次に進めてみます
自分に気づかない普通な人
自分が悪くない態度を維持する
この普通な人っていうのは
まあまあみんなほとんど普通ですからね
普通我々はいつでも心の中で自分が悪くないという態度を維持しています
ちょっと人と話が合わなくなっちゃうと
かなり凶暴で自分が悪くないぞとかかってくるじゃないですか
これが普通の人の性格なんです
自分は気づかないんですよ
ただ私が悪くない 私が悪くない
悪くないと言うだけで
私は何者かと知ろうとしないんです
自己観察より成功を重視する
我々知っている普通の世界で自分が何者かということはどうでもいいんです
何が成功しているかということを聞くんです
いつも まあそんなのは明確に説明しなくても
大体はわかることで 日常生活のことだからね
例えば泥棒やってでもお金儲けちゃって
これバレないようにいられればね
結構もう認めますよ 社会も
日本で麻原さんが犯罪者やとわかるまでは
最終解脱だよとものすごいみんな思っていたんだから
私にまで攻撃したんだから
あんた何何者かと思ってるんでしょうか
人を馬鹿にしてとか ずっと馬鹿にしていたんですけど
まあそれだけじゃなくて
今も日本に神様がいらっしゃってるでしょ
全知全能の森羅万物を創った神様が
私はもう馬鹿だと思っても
精神的な病気だと平気で言ってますけどね
嫌な顔するんですね その信者さんたちが
もうしょうがないんですけど
やっぱりこのなぜかというと
この成功は重視するんですよ
この本人が何者かということじゃないんです
だからいろんなインチキ宗教組織っていうのはたくさん日本であるし
誰もインチキなんだこれって宗教かっていう疑問は抱かないんです
なぜならば もう 110億
50億の建物を建てたり
お城を造ったりして もう天国みたいなものを造ったり
すごく信者さんこれぐらいいるんだ
これぐらい そうやってこの俗世間の成功を謳ってるんだから
みんなこの本人のことは気にしないんです
アナンさんと握手して写真見たら
さすが素晴らしいと我々の
様とかわかりませんだけど
お茶アナンさんと会っただけで
本人もそれぐらいの格の人方に別なことでノーベル賞をもらった誰か哲学者との話しましたけど
お茶飲みながら何でも喋れますけど
通訳つけて でも我々はその業績を見て認めるという普通の人間の心理学があるんです
だから普通の人間というのは
自己観察ではなくて 成功を重視するんです
後で足元すくわれますけどね
失敗は他人のせいにする
で これをちょっと強烈な言い方で
他人のせいにするっていうことは
だいたい私たち個人個人でいろんなことをやっていると
一人で山に入って何かすることでも仕事でしょうね
そうするともう転がっちゃって
足が怪我すると こちらがこんなものあったんだから怪我して
あの木の枝に文句を言うんです
大体他人にするんですよ
事故を起こしちゃうと
なんだこちらちゃんと標識がついてないのではないか
これで横から枝が出て見えなかったのではないかとかね
だから信号見えなかったのではないかとか
と枝に文句言う もうそこを管理する道路の誰か誰かに文句言う
たとえ信号が見えなくても
安全運転するのは当たり前のことでしょうに
安全運転するために信号は要りませんよ
道路を渡るためのあれも何も要りませんよ
ちゃんと道路を見ながら人が転んだ
じゃあブレーキっていうことでしょうに
こんな標識何一つも要りません
そこで安全運転するのは自分のよく仕事なのに
役目なのに 義務なのに
標識が見えなかった だから無罪だと
そこでいろいろ現場実験でなんとかなんとかやって
さすがその時標識は見えなかったとかね
言って人殺してるのに無罪にするということなんです
だから大体自分の失敗とか他人のせいにするというのは
普通の人間の生き方なんです
その代わりに自分の試みない自分がいい加減で運転したんだからではないかと
例えばどこかで この東京のどこかでトラックをバックして
ちっちゃな子供を潰して殺しちゃったでしょ
無罪にしたんですよ 見えないんだから
でも私は知ってる 運転手さんたち見ますよ
いきなり車ドア開けて座って
はいバックギアを入れません
結構ちょっと一回り行くんです
特に自分の国の場合は全て中古車だから
いつタイヤがパンクするかわからないし
どこか何が壊れるかわからないし
全部日本製でしょうし
だからもうかなりもう時間切れでしょうし
あるいは寿命すぎて時計セッティングして作る品物だから
だからでもそれ知ってるんだから
どこかで車止まったところでさっさと乗ってエンジンかけて行くっていうことは大体はしない
ちょっと一回りみたいな
ほんの秒のことなんです
だからもうそういうついというか
つっていうことは起こりません
だから 何て言いますか
気を付けるのは自分の仕事なんですよ
それを普通な人はしないんですね
事故を起こしたのをあの人のせいととにかく言いたがるんです
自分に不注意あったっていうことを認めちゃうと
もう終わりだからね 結局は
だからそれを例で考えてるって
人生は 事故を起こした場合は誰でも無罪になりたいんだから
免許はもう取り上げて欲しくないんだから
いろいろ嘘を言うかもしれませんだけど
それは知った上だったらね
まあしょうがないし ではなくて
日常生活の中で我々時間も自分の心見ないで他人のせいにする
家のお子さんがいつでも旦那さんの悪口を探すんですね
家庭の問題は旦那のせいだと
それ旦那も子供の問題は奥さんのせい
そういう風にこの他人のことにして
もうまあ自分が悪くないという態度を維持するんです
まだたくさんあります
日常生活に追われていて
暇も余裕もありません
自分の心見る暇も余裕もないんです
いわゆる私が今説明しているのは
この本音知らないと意外と気づかないと意外じゃないんです
本音に気づくはずもない
もう余裕暇がないんですよ
忙しくて それならそれなりに流れてる人生に酔っている
大体人生っていうのはそれなりに流れてるでしょ？別にキンキラキンキラ金で万々歳状態ではないんだけど
それなりにまあまあ生きてるんだから
それに酔っているんです
だから自分の心は見劣はしない
はい  13番目に行きます
それでまた自分に気づかない普通の人
この自分に気づかない普通の人っていうのは
意外と本音で生きてるんです
ただごまかし上手だけ
ずるがすごいというかね
これちょっとケタ違う
ずるがすごいと言えないんです
バレないんだから 本当に普通の人っていうのは意外と本音で生きてます
本音と言えば 2つ  3つですよ
もうこれで幾分本音の定義が入ります
人間の本音っていうのは大体 3つです
1つは欲中心に成功を目指す本音
成功したい いい人と結婚したいとかね
いい仕事を見つかりたいとかね
まあいろいろ  2番目は怒り中心に勝利を目指す
負けたくないでしょ 誰でも
勝ちたいっていうのは本音なんです
それは怒り中心のことなんです
それで 3番目は無知中心に言われる通りにこなす
何だかんだでマニュアル通りに見事にやってみせる人間が
いわゆる良い人間を演じる
この何でしたっけ このファーストフードレストランやら
そういうところでもね
大体若者バイトで雇うでしょ
マニュアル通りに見事にテキパキとやってくれると
まあありがたい ありがたい
まあ若いんだから元気もあるし
体力もあるし もう可愛いし
それでもうテキパキと動いて
きちんとマニュアル通りに食べ物はちゃんとパックあげたりして
結構役に立ちますよ みんな褒める
いい子だ いい子だとかね
そこで誰でもいい子になりたいんですよ
もうおじさんになっても会社で 55歳
60歳でも やっぱりいい子にはなりたいんですよ
このいい子を演じようとするのは
無知中心なんで 結局は
いい子になるためには
相手言うことははいはいとYESなんで
はいはいと言って従えばいいんです
これでいい子なんです
言う通りやってくれるんだから
これが本音なんです 自分で計画を立てて
自分で新しいプロジェクト作って
自分で苦労してっていうところよりは
どなたが立てたプロジェクトで
あなたはこの一部をやってくださいと言ったら
はいはい わかりました
やってあげますということでやってあげるだったらやります
自分で責任取りたくないんです
これが無知中心の生き方なんです
いい子を演じるっていうこと
しかし 自分の本音を決して認めないのは特色です
こういうミスはあるんだけど
誰も認めません それは
何言うんでしょうかと
仏教っておかしいんではないかと言うんです
例えばこのいい子 良い人間演じてる人々は
おじいさんになっても
あいつは退職することになって
私はもう 28 年間もすごく正直で真面目で会社に尽くして仕事をしてきたんだぞと
と言うんでしょうし アホでしたとは言わないんです
ただ仕事をやって 毎日仕事をして
命令通りに仕事をして
まあそこそこもうなんとかなんとか生きていて
それでも追い出されたと
一旦会社辞めたっても
どうったことはない ちっぽけのもうほんのわずかなあれ
何て言いますか この退職金もらって
それでもう人生ももう体もガタガタもう壊れているし
私はもうバリバリこれこれやったと威張ったりする
しかし ちゃんとした仕事人間だったら
仕事を辞めても人格で見えるはずなんです
ちょっと怖いはずなんです
でもだらしないでしょう
この会社に毎日行くことなくなっちゃうと
ネクタイつけて きちんとスーツを着て
履いて 会社に行くことをやめたその次の日からもうだらしないのです
あれっていうのは みんないい子を演じていただけなんです
それで私は真面目にもう無欠勤というんですか
無欠勤で会社にも 28年も行ったぞとかね
言うんであって 私はろくでもない無知でしたとは言わないんです
無知だから もう言う通りにやっただけですと
わかりませんとは言わない
だから本音っていうのは言わないんです
認めないんです それは無知なこと
欲中心なことでも同じことで
これは普通の人の本音です
はい というわけで と言ってもね
本音に気づく 気づいて生きることは辛いんですよ
自分が無知だから 何もできんだから
もうみんなに頭下げてはいはいしてるんだった
これ認めるのはすごく辛いんですよ
生き生き続けたいです
続けたいですかね わからない
生き続けたいという生存欲があるから
防衛のために心が本音はないことにしているのです
だから本音認めることは難しい
辛い もう生きていられなくなります
それで我々はある手段をとります
防衛します 何なのかというと
本音なんかないんだと
ないことにする ものすごい人々がいるんですよ
自分の気持ちなんか振り返るっていうことはまるっきりしないと
無茶機械のごとく働いている
時々旦那に不満を持ってる奥さんたちは
まあ子育てにも無茶な無知があって
むちゃくちゃ頑張るんです
なぜかというと あんなものは考えちゃうと
もう嫌で辛いんですよ
だからもう本音なんかはないということで
まぁとにかく無知になっても頑張るんです
それで終わっちゃうと
もう自分にはもう生きる意欲も意味もなくなっちゃうんです
一般的にも本音 建前のフレーズは褒め言葉ではありません
だからこの本音で生きることは辛いんだからね
本音に気づくこと 生きることではなくて
だからなかったことにする
ないことにする ないことにするために本音建前という
これは明らかに日本文化から我々がフレーズなのに
日本語でもそんなに褒め言葉ではないんですよ
面接の時でも ではあなたの建前言ってください
はい わかります では本音言ってくださいってないでしょ
面接でも本音聞くでしょ
それで相手が建前言うでしょ
互いに騙し騙し合いで両方騙されてる
なんてバカなことかわからないんだけど
面白いんです 面接では
面接時間がもう本音聞いてるんです
そこで受ける側が私はねとか
まろっ切り立てまいなんです
はい またありますよ 自分に気付かないことは
しかし ないことにしている本音は反乱を起こす
本音なんかないとして
気楽に機械みたいに生きてたっても
結局は本音があ反乱を起こすんですよ
反乱っていうのは精神的なトラブル起きたり
自殺したり 私はよく聞いているのは
お母様たちのおばあちゃんになっちゃったら
一体私の人生って何なのかというと
別にわかるでしょう 鏡見ればもうボロボロ
年を取るだけのことなんですけど
もうやっぱりもう旦那に裏切れたとかね
子供たちは一人ももう来ないとかに尽くしてあげたのにとかね
嫌な女の子と一緒になったとかね
もう親御さんのことはもう何て言いますか
大事になって 私のことはもう全然見ようともしないとかね
それは本音の反乱なんです
本音が反乱しているんです
本当は子ども育てるのは自分のためなんです
それは隠さないと いえいえ
私は母だから とんでもないと
もっとそんなこと考えていないと思ってやったのに
やっぱり後で反乱を起こすんです
人間関係で悩む だから本音はなかったことにしちゃうと
人間関係では悩むんですよ
物事上手にいかない時
また悩む 苦しむ だから悩む必要ないでしょうに
本音がなければ だから物事うまくいって儲かるぞとか
あるいは勝利得るぞとかね
あるいは良い子良い子だと背中叩いてくれるぞと思っているんです
本音っていうのはミスだから
儲かるか 勝利を得るか
背中を叩いてくれるか
どちらか  3つのどちらかなんです
これがうまくいかないと落ち込むんですよ
悩むんです 期待が外れると落ち込んだり悩んだりする
それでやる気もなくなります
だから本音を無視してはいけないんですよ
なかったことに ないことにしてはいけない
こういう影になります
本音があるんです それに生きる意欲もなくなったりする
異常な行動をする あるいは突然ね
会社の普通の人がなんかいきなり車で駅に入り込んじゃって何人か殺ったとかあるでしょ
異常なことも突然してしまうんですよ
それはすべて本音はないということにして
ないことにしてやっているんだからなんです
なんでないことにしたんですかというと
それに もう生きていられないんですよ
本音がわかると だからまあ一応ないことにしましょうと
もうタンスの中に入れておくんですね
やがてこんなことになっちゃうんです
そうすると 自分に気づく
なくす なかったことにするより認めた方が良い
これが一応私の あの 何て言いますか
アドバイスというか 治療方法なんです
本音は本音に気づくのはつらいかもしれませんだけど
じゃあ認めた方がいいよと
本音は単純なものではなく
複雑な合成なのです だから本音っていうのは認めましょうって言ってもちょっと難しいんです
本音 今 3つ説明したでしょ
でもちょっと複雑な合成なんです
それは第2のテーマです
次回やります だから認めましょう
で言ったっても ちょっと難しい
その時その時気づいた本音を認めることで精神的に楽になるのです
例えば 自分がやったことは
相手から見ればもうバカなことだとバレちゃった
あんたバカなこと認めればいいんです
やっぱりバカでした やっぱりまずかったと
やっぱり怒ったと 何か仕事に出したところで
その人はもう相手とちょっと話がうまくいかなくて
なんか何か言い訳みたいなものをして
もうもうダメになった場合は
会社に戻ったらどういうどういうことですか？と
あんた怒ったんではないか
やっぱり怒りましたと
その時正直に認めた時は精神的には楽なんです
だから我々の本音っていうのはもうグルグル変わっちゃいますから
ある時はバカ ある時は怒る
ある時はもういろいろあります
やっぱりあれは欲でしたねとかね
例えば奥さんにものさんざんいじめられて苦しめられていて
大変きつい 食事も作ってくれない
これでいちれば殺している
これでごちゃごちゃではなくて
なんでやっぱりあれ欲でしたね
私は女に手出したんだから
と言えば もう奥さんの前でも平気で
まあしょうがない いじめられたっても
やっぱり自分が女に手を出しちゃったんだからとか認めると問題解決しますよ
自分にとっても苦しくない
対応できます 生きていられます
それで精神的な悩みはそれなりに気づくたびに本音を認めることで
他人に言うことでなくなるのです
何に関係するか私にわかる
何か間違っている あ これは英語で読めばわかると思います
ちょっと英訳してみます
ちょっと私も焦って文法は日本語のスタイルになってないだけ
あの後ろから読めばわかります
その場合は他人に言うことでなくなるんですよ
悩みは 他人に言っちゃえばなくなるんです
それでその時その時言っちゃえばいいんです
私は一生バカよと言うんじゃなくて
やっぱりあれがバカなことでしたと
そのケースバイケースで言えばいいんです
例えば血糖がある 何て言いますか
この糖尿病なのにすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないのに
まあどこかへちょっと散歩に行ったところで食っちゃったと
もう何かアイスクリームかソフトクリームかケーキかとか
そこでいきなりまたもう上がってしまって
結構大変なことになったと
その時でもやっぱりもう欲しかったとか
やっぱり我慢できなかったと
欲出したと そのケースバイケースで我々は失敗するんです
だからこの私は一生バカでしたとかね
一生欲張りということはないんです
私は死ぬまで女を見るたびに手を出すんだとかね
そんなのは全くありません
まあたまたまなんとかのことでそうなっちゃうだけなんです
だから その時その時やったことは
その時その時すぐ認めちゃう
そういうことで 結構もう危険
いわゆるこのやったことが悪いんだから悪い結果になるでしょ
それはすぐもうそんな大事に至らず終わっちゃう
だから気づくたびに本音を認めることで
だから私は言うのは本音に気づいてくださいと
しかし これ一個じゃないんです
本音は ある日本音に気づいて
それで万々歳終わったってわけじゃないんです
本音っていうのはもう瞬時に変わるんです
だから なかなかいつでも気づかないんです
しかし 気づいたらすぐ認めてほしい
これで結構精神的なストレスがなくなるんですよ
ニコニコと笑っていられます
そういうことです 明るい人はよくやることです
それは 大体明るい人 明るいっていう場合
その場合なんですよ もう大体この女の子なんかはよく喋るでしょうに
一人でも喋る 二人でも喋る
もうもう何でも喋る でも結構あれで明るいでしょうね
あれはなんていううるさいなと悪口言ってる男も
あれ結構喜んでるんですよ
本当は あのうるさい連中がなくなっちゃうと
なんかすごく寂しくなるんです
いる時はうるさいよと言ってますけどね
なぜかというと 女の人っていうのは
その都度その都度思ったことはバンバンバンバンと言っちゃうんです
だから男性よりはストレスは少ないんです
ああ 嫌だとかね 何やってるんですか？とかね
もうすぐすぐもうその場でその場にも怒ったら別にちょっと感想かっこつけなくちゃとかはないんですよ
女の人は もう社長にでも怒るんだから
もう新入社員なのに だからそれで一応女性にはね
すごく生存欲というかね
それは付いてるんだから
この自然法則によって心もできているんです
長生きできるために 男はもう早く死んだ方が世のためになるんだから
そういう能力はついてないんです
でも女の人は早く死んじゃうと困るんですよ
生命は  そういうことだから
女の人っていうのは平気で人に向かっていろんなことを言うんですよ
男には信じられない こんなこと言って大丈夫かなと
でも大丈夫なんです だからそういうケースで
この明るく健康で精神的なストレスなく生きる方法っていうのはこちらで女の人に学んでください
はい それで別なテーマ
本音と建前の関係 ケース 3つ書いてます
ケース１ ケース１っていうのは
本音と建前が全く分かれています
関係ないという まるっきり違うもの
これは精神分裂状態で危険です
で 時々私たちもそんなある時そうなるんですよ
本音と建前とまるっきり違った動きとかね
これほんのわずかな時間でも気をつけた方がいいんです
それは結構一生だったらまあ分裂病気でまあしょうがないんですけど
そこでケースツーは本音と建前がダブってるんで
ダブってるんじゃなくて重ねてるんで
いくらか それは普通な人間なんです
本当は建前っていうのは建前で
本音っていうのは誰にも言わないものなんですよ
それだけが一番目はいいんですよ
言うんだけど 一番はすごく危険なんです
普通人間二番目なんです
ちょっとあるところまで重ねているんです
本音で建前 それでケースさんはもうほとんど重ねています
建前なんかはあるのかというぐらい
その場合はもう私はもう無謀者ですよ
野蛮人ですよ だって思ったことを言っちゃうし
やりたいことをやっちゃうし
そういう風にこの人間持ってる本音と建前っていうのは三つの関係があるんです
世間一般的にはこの二番目のケースでやってます
はい それでまた同じこと
本音と建前の人間関係
自分というのはなんか私は決めた色が出てこないんですね
なんかわからない  それなりの色分けはしたつもりですけど
スクリーンには映らないんです
自分というのは当たり前
本音と建前ですね こちら書いてるように
自分というのは本音と建前で自分であって
そこで一 二 三という三つの関係があるんです
一というのは本音だけの関係
これは普通の人の場合
健康な人の場合 野蛮人のことを勉強しても意味がないんだから
我々には それで普通の人の本音だけだったら
自分の主観的な世界 自分だけの世界
二番目の関係っていうのは
親しい人々や関わりのある人々の関係
これ二番目どうなってるかというとダブってますよ
この何色ですか これは
このかなりきつい色で開けたら
この本音の 本音と建前のカットする部分なんです
いわゆる建前と本音の一部で接しているんです
関係持ってるんです 親しい人々と
その通りでしょうね 親しい人々の場合は
建前だけでは会わない
接しません 建前と本音はごちゃになっているんです
しかし 他人との関係の場合は建前だけなんです
そういう関係で我々は生きているんです
本音と建前の関係 まあわかりやすいんだから次に行きましょう
そこで問題点があります
一の関係 妄想の回転なんですよ
一っていうのは この自分
本音だけの関係 本音だけっていうのは自分だけの世界なんですよ
自分だけの世界に飛び込んでいるということは
妄想の回転であって すべての問題の元ですから
これが人間の問題の元なんです
全然問題にしない これが原因なのに
誰も問題にしないんです
気づかない 難しくなるかな
こういうこと 自分が一人勝手に考えることだから
別に誰に迷惑じゃないんじゃないかなと
と思うんですよ 例えば一人でいろんなくだらんこと
いろんなことを妄想したりする
そこで別にあんた方に関係ないんだよと
私はちゃんと仕事をしているのではないか
だから私の妄想なんか放っておけという態度を取りますよ
人は何か考えるのは自由ではないか
だから何考えたっていいじゃないか
何をイマジネーションしたってもいいんじゃないかと思う
悪くないと しかし 仏教から見ればそれが問題なんです
それであらゆる苦しみ
すべて現れてくるのです
それで仏教と俗世間は全く反対立場なんです
皆様でも考えるだけだったらどうってことないと思ってるでしょ
[笑い]例えば旦那が早く死んでしまえと思って
あれは思っただけだから
別にそんなこといいんじゃないかと言ってないんだから
という風な感じになるんですよ
これすごい危険ですよ
危険ということを証明するために
一つ 時々若い男たちなんかはもう部屋に入り込んじゃって
いろいろ漫画見たり 汚い映画見たり
インターネットでいろんなものを見たりして
もう妄想の世界で生きている
そのまま電車に乗ったりしちゃうと
女の子を見たりするでしょうよ
もうなんだかわからなくなっちゃって
なんとかするでしょう
だから危険でしょう すごく危険です
で 本人が気づくときは重症になっている
自分の妄想に気づいている場合はもう重症ですよ
ほとんど治らないんです
次にの関係があります
トラブルが起きても自分で処理できると思っている
これはの関係っていうのは
この親しい人々の関係
その場合は奥さんと喧嘩する
子供とぶつかったりする
親戚と何とかやっちゃう
会社で同僚と何とかぶつけたりする
そういう親しい人々の間でぶつかると
みんな威張って これはうちの問題だから何とかできるんだよと
手に負えない時は他に頼る
例えばあれはもう家内のことだから自分で何とかしますと
お母さんにこれはうちの子供のことだから私は何とかしますとか
なんかすごく自分で何でもできそうな感じでいるんです
親しい人々の関係では
でもできない時ありますよ
その時は誰かに言うんです
あの ずっと 25 年間も一緒にいた奥さんが
全く知らない人に うちの旦那にこれこれ言ってくれませんか？とかという時
頼む時ありますよ カウンセラーのところに行って
それでカウンセラーが旦那に電話をかけて
実は奥さんはこういうこういうことでとかね
言わなくちゃいけない
夫婦だから言えばいいという
それは成り立たない やっぱりこの親しい関係で起きたトラブルが手に負えないことになりましたということ
そこまでは自分でできると威張ってます
できないんですけど はい
で 誰にでも誰でも気にするのは第三の関係です
みんなよく気にするのは第三の関係
いわゆる世間との関係
他人との関係 普通はそれほど大きい問題は起きません
この他人との関係でほとんど問題は起きませんよ
親しい人との関係で問題が起きるんだけどね
他人とは別に 例えば性格が悪い男が
もしかすると自分の奥さんといつでもトラブってトラブって喧嘩ばっかりして
奥さんに手を上げる可能性ありますよ
だからって世の中の女に手を上げませんよ
[笑い]いくら性格悪いと言っても
全く関係ない人に嫌なことを言われたっても
別にぶん殴ろうとはしない
だからやっぱり第三者のというか
他人との関係 これは 3番目の関係ではあんまり問題起きません
普通はそれはない 他人との関係が上手でない人は控えめでいれば十分なのです
例えば 世間とうまくいけない人
学校であのみんな代表してステージに上がって喋ることはちょっとできない
だったら控えめればいいでしょう
そんなに だからこの第3番目の関係っていうのは
ただできないんだったら自分を控える
それで終わりですよ なのに世間で本あるばは上手に話し方
上手な挨拶の仕方 厚い本ばっかしで
あんなの本は要りません
自分には他人と上手に喋れないんだったら黙っていればいいんですよ
皆さん 例えば どうしても会社の関係でバカでかい晩餐会みたいにパーティーに行ったと
みんなお互いにベチャベチャベチャベチャ喋ってるんですけど
自分にはあんまり上手じゃない
英語もそんなに喋れないし
いろいろ外人と習慣 習慣もそれぞれ違うし
だったらちょっとまあ知ってるような感じで
じゃあという感じで 一言自分でパクパク食べて帰っちゃえばいいでしょう
終わる時はみんなにちゃんと握手ぐらいして
ではよろしくよろしく
もううまくいったことになるんですよ
何も喋ってないのに だからそんな問題じゃないんですよ
会社と関係 社会との関係っていうのは
なんでそんな大げさにするか私にはわかりません
これで八方美人的世界制覇する生き方です
こんなのはね 大体みんなこの八方美人的な生き方をしようとしている
八方美人にならなくてもいいんです
世界制覇しなくてもいいんですよ
あの すごく説明しちゃうと長くなりますからね
そこら辺はまあ簡単にやめられます
いわゆる 何でしたっけ
この第3番目の関係問題は簡単に解決できます
そこで問題点 順序逆さま
1自分との自分の主観の妄想の世界
2番目は親しい人との関係
3番目は世間との関係という
我々は本音と建前の関係は 3種類でやってるんです
本音建前というと2じゃない
2つじゃないんです これは関係3つです
その時は実は 1は十で
2は中で  3は形なんですよ
世間との関係 大胆なことじゃない
10というのは自分の内の本音だけのからくりなんです
しかし 右見てください
世間はこの順番で考えている
世間に人々に聞くと 自分との頭の中の妄想って
あんなのは別に気にする必要ないやと親しい人々の関係
ものは家族の関係だから別になんとかするぞと
えらい軽く見るんです
世間との関係はすっごく重く思っちゃうんです
何のこともないのに だから逆さまなんです
だから世間は全然うまくいかないんですよ
そういう逆さま論理だから
それから仏教の説 仏教の話
やっと仏教の話になりました
読むだけでも十分だと思います
本音と建前のギャップは
仏教では大きい問題として見てみなしてない
あそこまで説明したんだけど
私は仏教から見ると別にアンタはもううるさい
そんな喋る必要もないやという態度なんです
本音と建前については
仏教でそんなに問題は扱ってないんです
本音を完全清浄することは音色です
仏教の仕事は建前云々というんじゃなくて
人の本音を完全に清浄すること
綺麗にすることなんです
建前でも悪い人間は稀なのです
仏教から見れば建前でもうではないんですよ
建前は  建前はか そうですね
建前だけで考えるという意味なんですね
建前を基に 建前に関してはなんです
建前に関しては悪い人間が稀なのです
明白な悪人のことを誰でも知っている
なぜならば この建前でも悪人というのはみんな知ってますよ
法律はその人を裁くために構成している
悪人を裁くために法律もあるでしょうに
別に仏教はいらん 文明社会では簡単に管理できる建前は
文明社会での建前管理する社会でしょうに
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
だから当たるべきなのはもう本音なんです
私たちは人を殺してはいけないんだから
自分の首飛んじゃうでしょ
だから殺せませんよ 殺したくなっても建前ではやりません
気をつける だから悪人はいません
たまたまいるんでよ すぐわかる
その人はおかしいと はい
それで日本では世間を世間の目を気にするという言葉がありまして
英語だったらグッドマナー
ソーシャルという言葉がありますね
そんなもんなんです 建前の場合は
建前の正常か建前の管理はグッドマナーというマナーを守れば建前は完璧です
あるいはわかりやすけば
何事これを犯すなかれと
するなかれという態度で言えばそのもんですよ
何何を禁止すると言えば
もうやめ それで終わりますよ
すごい単純です 建前というのは
仏教では戒を守りなさいと言っているのは
建前の生き方の整理なのです
仏教ではこの戒律ということがありまして
みんなそれに悪口を言うんです
仏教はうるさいとかね
まあ精神的な病気でしょうね
本音で生きたいですよね
おそらく そんなことはないんですよ
ただの建前をいい加減にしなさいというぐらいのことなんです
しかし 誰もがわかってはいるが
やめられない心境で悩んでいるのです
建前で戒律なんかつけても
みんなわかっているんですよ
嘘言ってはいけないと
殺してはならんと わかっているんだけどね
怠けてはあかんと でもなかなかやめられないんですよ
それが問題 だからそれを仏教でアプローチするんです
はい 世間でいう道徳 規則
決まりなどは間違っているとは言えないが
問題があります 世間でいろんな宗教でも学校でも皆様の会社でも道徳というものはありますよ
教えてくれますけど 別に間違ってはないんだけど
問題があるんです 正しく成立させてないのです
問題は こういうわけでやってはいけないということは言ってないんです
人を納得させることができない
例えば会社でガチャガチャ言われても
あまり納得してないでしょう
時々は今年のモットーはこれこれですと
あなたのもうあれ 何て言いますか
あの 分担当てること え個人
目標 目標 ノルマ あなたのノルマはこれくらいと言ったってもね
納得いく？嫌でしょうに
ノルマかけられるの それどう解くかですね
かけられたノルマは見事に果たすものではないかとかね
それこそあれではないかと
いろいろ言うんですよ
だから なぜ悪いのかという義に答えはない
普遍性はない 世間の道徳では普遍性はない
キリスト教は自分勝手な道徳を語っているわ
ユダヤ教は自分のために道徳を語っているわ
もういい加減で普遍性はない
日本人は日本人の好き勝手な道徳を語るわ
アメリカ人はアメリカ人の好みの道徳を持っているわ
例えばね 民主主義といっても
アメリカの定義と他の国の定義違うでしょうに
あのベネズエラではみんなの賛成で民主主義と思って言ってるけど
アメリカはそれは間違っていると
何人かの賛成は民主主義だと思って平気で言うんです
だからそれぞれ定義違う
いい加減で道徳も同じですよ
普遍性はない はい えーと
それで仏教の道徳 仏教でこういうことを言うんですよ
本音が汚れているから
建前の生き方も悪 悪になる
結局は私たちの本音が汚れている
臭い だから本音の上にできている建物も臭いんですよ
だから悪になるんです
世間の目を気にして悪いことをやめても良いが
ただそれだけでは良い人間にはなりません
なれません 世間の目を気にしてね
不倫もしないでいても悪くないんですよ
隣にバレるんだから 不倫しなかったと
でもそれでいい人間になったわけじゃないんです
団地のばあちゃんは ばあちゃんの連中
すごくうるさいんだから
結構気をつけたんだと
それはいいんだけど 自分が立派な人間になったわけじゃない
やっぱり本音が臭いんだから
本音を直さなくちゃいけないんです
内の汚れを落とす目的で社会の道徳を守るのです
そこで仏教が言うのは
会社の言うことを守りなさい
学校が言うことを守りなさい
世間言うことを守りなさい
それは何なのかというと
会社が正しいというわけじゃない
学校は完璧というわけでもない
世間の連中は頭いいわけでもない
みんないい加減なことを言ってるんだよと
時々子供文句言うでしょ
なんで学校あんなこと言うんでしょうかと
例えば女の子なんかは15
6歳になってくると ちょっと口紅とか塗りたいでしょうね
耳にちょっと何かつけたいでしょうね
これが学校は鬼のように反対する
その代わりに学校終わったら体売ってもいいということにしてるんです
そういうことをするんだから
子供たちが大変危険な状態になっている
それで女の子がおしゃれしたいんだからね
理解できない 何が悪いんですかと
口紅ぐらいしたっても
ちょっとネックレスぐらいつけたっても
その時親はこう言うべきですよ
君は言ってることは本当
毎日おしゃれしてかっこよく行った方がいいよと
でもあの学校の連中にはそれがわからない
それは学校だけじゃなくて
この日本の教育システムにもそれわからないんだと
でもだから問題はそちらじゃなくて
この学校の決まり守ると君がいい人間になる
君のわがままがなくなる
君が忍耐強い人間になる
だから世間に説教することを置いておいて
あなたはいい人間になりなさい
だけど守りなさいと だからみんな並びなさいと言ったら並んじゃえばいいんですよ
並ばなくてもいいのに
みんな並んでるのに自分だけゴチャゴチャやってるとだらしないと見えますよ
だからこの道徳は何のために守るかというと
世間で言われるから 聖書に書いてあるからじゃないんです
神様もいわゆるもう何とかではからではないんです
ただ それで自分の本音が綺麗なんです
守ってみると 例えばわかりやすい例で
子供がなんであの人に挨拶しなくちゃいけないかと言うかもしれません
しかし 子供がちゃんと挨拶すると
挨拶された側が あ いい子だと
言うし 自分も自己管理できる人間になるんです
だから自分ができた人間だということを確認するために
できた人間になるために道徳を守るんです
えーと 悪の本音と戦いながら戒を守るのは難しい
厳しい 苦しい というのは言われるんだからやるのは苦しいんですよ
例えば不倫してはいけないと
誰が決めたかわからないんだけど
まああるんですね 世の中に
これおかしいのは日本人なんかは
日本の文化はまあなかなかもんで
我々の文化から見ると
でもなんか最近になって
最近でもないんだけど
明治維新からもうなんかあのくだらないヨーロッパ人の道徳を守っているんですね
日本では一人の人は女の人の人
3人とか一緒にいたことないんじゃなかったっけ
なんで一人の男が 2人の女と結婚して悪いんですかね
誰が決めたんですかね
逆もそうでしょ なんで一人の女の人はもう男 2人と結婚して悪いんですかね
いっぺん それはだいたいみんな考えてないんですけど
別にどちらでも同じですけど
まあまあ子供 まあ子供もんだから
やっぱり父親は誰かと発見しなくちゃ困りますからね
大体女はそれはあまり好きじゃないんです
でも男は女 3人と結婚したってもね
父親は自分だから問題ないんですよ
でもそれがなんで悪くなったんですかね
そうやってこの世間知らないうちに余計な関係ない道徳が生える
そういう道徳入っちゃって
日本の男は何するかというと
結婚したならばそれから不倫するべきやと
好きに思っちゃうんです
そうするとだらしないんですよ
私が言うのは 男と女二人だけ結婚するべき
それ以上はダメということもいい加減ですよ
男は人  3人の女と結婚したってもどうったことはないんです
何の道徳も破ったことになりません
責任持てば だから一夫一婦制度っていうのはもう誰が決めたかわからないんですよ
いい加減誰か決めたでしょう
でも一旦世の中にそれ行き渡ると守るんですよ
不倫はしない なぜかというと
やっちゃうと自分が情けない
自分がだらしない 自分が根性が弱いということになります
ただそれだけ だから道徳の論理なんかはどうでもいいんです
守れない自分がだらしないという風に言うのは仏教の言い方なんです
これすごく難しいかもしれません
私が言ってるポイントは
道徳そのものには大した意味がありません
赤信号を渡ってはいけないということには大した意味がないんです
ぶつからなくて渡ってもいいんです
車に でも赤信号で渡るとだらしないでしょう
アホじゃないかと思っちゃうでしょう
あんた野生動物ですか？と思えるでしょう
だから自分のプライドを守ってしっかりと守ればいいんです
皆様はよく訓練するナイフとフォーク
なんとかな使い方とかあるでしょうに
スパゲッティなんか手で取って食べて何が悪い
それですごくもう膝を駆けつけないで
きちんとスプーン持って
それ上でスパゲッティを丸めてちゃんと口に運ぶとか
そうでなきゃといういろいろ訓練まで受けるんですね
バカバカらしい そんなのは
で 私は言うのは しかし
スパゲッティを手で食べると悪くないんだけど
これがスプーンでフォークで食べるものやと思ってるバカどもたちが
アホな人間がだらしないと思うんですよ
カッコ悪い だったらこちらもあんたよりもっと立派にやってみせるぞとやればいいんです
私はそうやるんで 私はもう生まれてたかからも手で食べる人間ですけど
でももうビクッとこう
フォークやらナイフやらね
もう動かしてみせます
何のこと？全然訓練を受けたことはない
だから それが物事を自分が観察して
すぐ寸地に寸地に勉強するものであるという自分のプライドなんです
ただそれだけ だから道徳そのものっていうのはね
くだらないものでも関係ないんです
ただ一旦守れない自分がだらしないということで
本音を育てるために守るんです
仏教の立場はそういう立場なんです
はい 進んでください 仏教の見解
私は何でしたっけ？良い人間になりたい
心を清らかにしたい 幸福になりたい
悩み苦しみがなく 明るく生きたいという
しかし そう簡単に上手にいかないのです
それは神のたたりでも
運命でも 社会のせいでも
時代の問題でも 親のせいでもありません
私は良い人間にならないのだ
まったくの気づかない本音の問題です
本音に気づかないんだから幸せになれないんですよ
心清らにならないんです
良い人間にならないんですよ
本音に気づき 清浄にすれば
絶望の願いは叶うものなのです
本音に気づくと 願うことは叶いますよ
気づいただけじゃダメ
本音ちょっと洗わないと臭くならないように
本当に簡単ですよ はい
それで話は終わり まあちょっと余分に
もう余分に言う時間がないんですけど
もう早く終わると思ってたのに
お釈迦様の言葉 ナタンマーターピターカイラ
これで間違ってカイラなんです
ナタンマーターピターカイラ アンニエワーピチャニャータカ サンマーパニヒタンチッタン セイヤソナンタトーカリ
初めてパーリ語を目にする方々はもうなんだこれと思うかもしれませんだけど
これはお釈迦様が説法なさった言語なんです
だから相当古い言語なんです
いまだに我々は使っているんです
ナタンマーターピターカイラ
母にもできないぞ 父にもできないぞという訳なんです
アンニエワーピチャニャータカ
他の親戚にもできないぞと
何が？こんな立派なことをやってくれることはできないぞと
何かというと サンマーパニヒタンチッタン
自分の心を制御しちゃうと
自分の本音なんですよ
本音制御すると自分はいかに幸福になるかというと
こんなことは母にもできない
してあげることできないんだと
正しく制御した己の心が自分を優れたものにする
それは母にも父にも他の親戚にもしてあげることはできないのです
お母さんいくら踏ん張ってもできない
だから私は世界一幸福になれますよ
私が私の本音をちょっと
ちょっと管理すれば いじめることをしないで
それでアッターハヴェージタンセイヨヤーチャヤンイタラパジャ
このヤーチャヤンイタラパジャっていうのは
この世の中にある全ての人々
全ての人々に貸すよりも自分に貸すこと素晴らしいんだ
それからこの104 105
までありますけど 100
行の偈でこれ書いてないんですけど
自分に勝ったならば世界制覇するんじゃなくて
自分を制覇する 自分を制覇している勝利は
どんな神にも奪うことはできません
どんな梵天にも 誰にも
自分が負けません それくらい勝利を得られますよ
自己管理で 自己管理っていうのは本音の管理なんです
これで終わりとします
それで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]